so we'll we'll commence the meeting are
there any
apologies I think
not um so item two is the election of a
chairperson do we have a nomination for
that position please I'd like to
nominate Phillips to so that's nominated
by glenis and um uh seconded um by
councelor Stringer um any other
nominations no all those in favor say
I Against carried in your hands
nille thank you Mr Deputy Mayor um and
thank you um my learning colleagues
beside me uh for the uh endorsement of
becoming the chair of uh the grants
committee I'm looking forward to the
challenge and um as the had already uh
invited and welcomed the participants um
we're going to first start off
with
the um Mata oh I'm coming up
here Mata Historical Society if You'
like to come forward and just come up to
the microphone and do your
presentation yeah
right um I'm Margaret young treasur of
the Mata historical society and this is
Jean Nelson who was uh one of our Val
committee members uh we're here
to um spill
uh about a grant for the Mata Historical
Society we get one every year and um
without it it's uh usually
9,500 uh dollars sorry and um without it
we would cease to exist
basically so um we're here on behalf of
the
museum
uh what do we what do we do
uh we fund rais twice a year to help
with their funds our grant just covers
our basic day-to-day living like
power uh
internet and uh rates and eive and
things like that so we have to R fund
raise twice a year
um anything extra we have
to uh like painting and repairs and
things you we used to we usually we have
to um yeah budget for those and um other
than
that uh we have a lot of schools through
through the museum we've had tutor
glenham when it was going uh Windam
Mata and also hope preschool and the
cangar
Rio uh
visitors we have quite a few visitors we
were open three days a week three
afternoons a week Friday Saturday and
Sunday
from uh 1:00 till 4:00 we have
a we have only about 12 volunteers that
um go on a roster to keep that going we
have a work day every Thursday for
things that come in and they're yeah um
the uh rostered uh yeah they're catalog
cataloged and put on the put on eive our
eive is on the online for everybody to
see is quite
popular and other than that um what else
is the
jeene
covers the what that probably covers we
have get donations but we don't
charge we have a if anybody wants to
leave a donation yeah they're quite
welcome um we have a few locals but a
lot of people come in just passing
through like from out of town uh we have
people that that are researching their
family trees and things that come in and
want to know
things um so
basically uh we're here here to we have
a gardener the gardens are looking
lovely at the
moment and we'd like to invite you all
to come and have a look at
it especially the museum and see what
what's what we have interactive displays
and things and um yeah we have a museum
an office and a store room out the back
it it's for everything that we can't
display all at once so uh we change
things quite regularly don't we and
everything that we've got is pertaining
to Mata we don't accept Goods outside of
matar if people want to give us
something it's got to have some mat
history about
it so are there any
questions uh thank you very much Jean
and Margaret um so is there any
questions want to put forward to
the
council what is a
ehive it's not a
beehive an ehive um that's where all
their things are cataloged and they're
numbered and they go on to ehive and you
just go into
mat historical society it's for everyone
to see yep and uh yeah if you want to
know something about
Mata that's the place to find it I think
there's over there's well over 4,000
things things
itemized on it so um and we're adding
more each each time each time we get
something in like we've just had a box
of photos coming at the
weekend and um yeah they were all
pertaining to Mata some were about the
marching club that we didn't really know
much of so yeah we were highly delighted
yeah 2,900 for insurance yes when was
that
last um with increasing insurances it it
increases every year yes yes when did
you pay the 00
um we pay it in monthly aor
mons yeah I think it's yeah it's um
nearly $300 a
month that covers I think that covers
the museum and we also have a public
liability that covers that as
well thank you Mr chair um I have
visited the museum and I think it's
truly wonderful and I congratulate you
on having such a great facility in
matara um I was just wondering about the
goods sold do you sell is that do people
bring in donations for you to sell to
make funding for the museum what no no
we have fruit trees around the
section and when the apples and the crab
apples are really
we make jelly and sell jelly apple or CB
apple
jelly that's fantastic that would be a
sale of
goods that's great and I see you've got
um like there's a donation box but you
get other donations as well so people
just donate money when they come in well
there was a
reunion early in the year a family
reunion it was held in Gore but a lot of
them pertain to the
Mata uh to the beles family which he had
been a mayor of
Mata and they visited the museum and the
cemetery on the weekend that they were
in Gore for and they gave us and and we
anything we had pertaining to the B
family and the mcquillin family we
sorted out and had it on
display and they gave us a nice donation
for that
no further
question well thank you very much G and
Margaret and I'll Enlighten the rest of
the counselors on what the actual eive
is and how it how it came yeah and how
it works and anybody can get into it and
see what we've got on display what we
not on display what we have got in in
storage thank you very much for coming
out today and presenting your um
submission and
uh we'll be in touch thank you very much
okay thank
you so the next one on the list
is Tracy would you like to come forward
thank
you the uh for the council is C Aviation
trust item number
two afternoon councilors um thank you
for the invitation to be here I would
have to say that it is a bit different
sitting on this side of the fence but at
least at this point everybody's smiling
so that's um that's always a bonus um so
of course my name is Tracy Hicks um uh
for my sins I'm the cheer of cordin
Aviation trust um I'm a brand new
trustee and um I'm really uh in a
privileged position to um to take on the
Cher's role I thought I knew a lot about
cording Aviation and until I've got
involved in the last three months but
certainly there's a lot more going on in
that part of the world than than I fully
realized um and of course one of the uh
other trustees is um a longtime um
server and that's mava Smith sitting
beside me so welcome mava um and but we
um I'd like to think that everybody on
the other side of the table if not
everybody in the room has visited cro
Aviation Museum and has a a general
understanding of of what it is and what
it does and why it exists
um it is quite hard uh financially to
make ends meet in an organization like
that there's just so much
potential um but actually getting to
that potential there's some some really
uh incredible stories of Aviation
Pioneers around this part of the world
but particularly across um southern New
Zealand and um that all uh all the
arrows Point toward U bandal at this
point so um in many ways it's a diamond
in the rough and it's one that I believe
will um will really shine and whether
it's this year next year or a number of
years later it's going to be a real um
magnet for this part of the world it's a
promotion for Gore District but it's um
it's a promotion for the whole of the
South and um we have U um people
requesting all sort sorts of um visits
uh visits um and having the airplanes
move to the part of the world uh
unfortunately not every one of them can
go uh around cost but certainly the
grant that comes from Council which is
really around um infrastructure uh and
um building operation uh is very greatly
received the building as you know is is
a big one uh there is it's not a an old
building but it does have a fairly high
level of Maintenance that's
required and um I guess my first
experience of cluster flies was in the
in the museum out there and certainly
they come in their tens of thousands um
my understanding is that cluster flies
aren't quite so much of a problem now U
because the birds have cleaned them out
but the birds are now becoming a bit of
a problem so you know one one person's
answer is another person's problem yes
um but certainly I can say on behalf of
the trustees uh around the table I think
there's seven six or seven of us um
every one of them appreciates the
relationship that we have with the
council have had for quite some
time uh and I'm sure most of you are
aware of the memorandum of understanding
that was signed between the trust and
the council in
2013 and I think it's pretty
straightforward um it's it's developed
as time has gone on and I'm sure it'll
develop into the future um but it does
seem to work pretty well F I'm I might
shut up for a minute and I don't whe M
wants
to I'm happy to answer
questions we um we certainly haven't
been practicing
this oh thank you Tracy a m um is there
any questions from
Council
Jo uh um thanks for turning up and
presenting um having like you're saying
it's going towards the the maintenance
of the building having been on the roof
of the building have you got the grass
out of the
speling well I haven't inspected it
myself Joe um but now you mentioned it
I'll come and have a look actually I saw
you up there one day and possibly you
could have taken out
yourself thank
you councel
McKenzie thanks for coming in I think
it's a wonderful setup you've got out
there I shouldn't really say this but I
absolutely love it what do you see in
the future say 10 15 years down the
track happening there all going well cuz
I I agree with what you're saying I
think it's a
diamond in the in the southern region
that needs to be developed what can be
done to to do that your thoughts well
it's it's um coincidental that you
mentioned that Robert at this time we're
just organizing a strategy day for the
trustees um my understanding is there
hasn't been one for some time and we
need to think about what 10 years out 20
years out looks like and and where we go
building what is already a very good
foundation but look I I can't give you
any definite answers there um but you
know relationships with Airlines
particularly New Zealand they take quite
an interest in the place they Haven
given any money yet but um you know some
of the aircraft are there they're very
early aircraft um so connections with um
those sort of organizations I think
would bring benefit and also people uh
to the to the
area thank
you everyone no further questions um
cancel I see that you've got
$99,000 in
loans um but also I I guess you've got
advances from other people as well um to
the loans and and the liabilities you've
got there create a potential
risk I don't believe so
um not sure what
you well it shows up on the records on
on the accounts here as current
liabilities loans oh sorry
$95,000 yes $95,000 there has since been
there has since been right okay that
might explain why the interest um yeah
right here so I don't think there a risk
there right yes thank
you I guess the the other aspect that
comes from it is that while um it was a
fairly minor amount in terms of
$6,000 um that you received to help with
the maintenance there's other
contributions that the council makes as
well um which are probably more
important and look I think it's a
symbiotic relationship with uh with the
council uh I think it works for both
parties really well it gives the council
a presence in other parts of the pro the
district as opposed to just being in
Gore from a um
uh public
relations
perspective so yeah there's certainly
other relationships that we have with
Council but I think that they work
pretty
well my understanding
anyway no further questions if
not thank you very much uh Tracy M for
um coming today and presenting your um
presentation um and we'll Julie get back
to you and inform you what the decision
will be for Council thank you councilors
I look forward to um reading the result
of your deliberations thank you and look
and thank you for the relationship that
we have not just with the councilors but
with the council officers because um if
it wasn't there um I think we'd both be
losers to be honest thank you thank you
thank
you councel we only have uh a next one
number three is the Southland
Gallery presentation from Mr gidy you
like thank you n um apologies from our
chair Hugh hesselman um daytime dur
working hours not particularly good time
for you but um I think everything is
pretty straightforward with regard to
the community Grant accountability form
um and certainly the eastn South and
gallery Incorporated greatly appreciates
the support of of cor District Council
um particularly towards the very basic
operations of the of the gallery which
has undertaken there um the gallery
itself was a joint venture initiative um
between Gore District historical society
and Gore Bar Council so I think every
very first GB Council Grant we received
in
1984 and again it was for the um very
basic operations there um looking at the
community grants policy that came with
the documents that um it sort of
obviously it acknowledges that um you
know 2.1 to support the district Art
Gallery Museum and acknowledge that the
gore district is an art center of
national importance and that its history
needs to be preserved um Houston South
and gallery Incorporated um likes to
think that it's contributing
significantly towards that um and also
you'll have note with you the memorandum
of understanding between GDC and east
and south and gallery Incorporated
signed in 20
um20 which clearly outlines the
expectations of council with regard to
um
kpis um tenic of
annually team performances activities
annually open to the public um it plays
an active role in Precinct wide
engagement of 50 schools and special
interest groups per anom most
importantly the gallery is open 361 days
perom and has a satisfaction rate from
visitors of greater than 80% so when you
look at the community grants
accountability form you'll see that um
uh the basic
costs of delivering that not only
running the gallery but delivering those
kpis um we're very grateful for the
community Grant because that accounts
for about approximately 27% of the um of
the annual operating costs and that
includes delivering those kpis that's
all the um other activity there so
there's a there's a breakdown of um the
grant figure the apportionments which is
again to very basic operating um we're
incredibly lucky to have a really
a stunning committee um they obviously
rais the other um 73% of the base
operating cost and they do that through
a variety of measures um advocating for
us at a local level at a national level
um also fundraising um helping us bring
Revenue in um interestingly the last
couple of years certainly
postco have been challenging on a on a
range of levels because um to physically
deliver those kpis in a sort of semi
lockdown situation has been a challenge
and then to do any fundraising as well
we work with a number of sponsors and
Community or funding organizations who
have been um in with us for the Long
Hall the committee has
deliberately left them alone for the
purpose of advancing the completion of H
moonshine Museum and the m center um
which has had Capital challenges
obviously so we're just so pleased that
we've got um a community of Interest
around what we're doing um which is
clearly celebrated in um uh not only
meeting the kpis but exceeding them on a
number of levels um and I think
hopefully delivering that required um
art gallery of national importance so
I'm very happy to answer any
questions I think it's fairly um
straightforward as per previous years um
the grant of $440,000 is is greatly
appreciated it has pretty much remained
um at that for the last certainly
preco um we've had two incremental
increases since year 200000 um so we're
very happy with the status quo in this
regard um we had some challenges as I
think every organization did with um the
significant drop interest rates so
anybody that had any term deposits that
and relied on the income from those we
certainly discovered that um uh
0.8% wasn't as good to work with as
their current
5.7 um but I have to congratulate the
committee and the team because everybody
just rolled their sleeves up made it
made it happen made it work I happy to
answer any
questions thank you J is there any
questions from Council that's
Council who who owns the building and
land the council owns a building a okay
because the reason for asking is that
your depreciation in a time when Council
asss have have gone up hugely with
depreciation um your depreciation
amounts have actually declined in the
last year yeah well that's because um
that's all relates to the FED out of the
museum
interesting the building itself the Cari
library was actually fully funded by the
Carnegie
Foundation um it was built for £
1,978 and you received a grant in 2000
uh 1998 for
2,000 um the addition which was $1.3
Million which was undertaken 19002
193 that was fully funded by external
funders um and so that has now owned by
the council because the council owns the
whole entity but we are still paying
depreciation on it um we also paying
depreciation on all our fittings which
we own which is your displays your
storage um all those other elements your
lighting um everything we are also um we
own these premises of school the outse
what building so clearly we've invested
the committee has
raised fully fundraised over $700,000 to
date which they've spent on the building
so obviously that is going to be
depreciated as well and that that
figures on there um we are as a society
obliged to fund
appreciation I see you have tomb
deposits of close to
500,000 what's the purpose of them um
the they are bequests that have been
specifically given to the gallery um
bequests that offset the insurance uh
costs on the collection um the others we
have
um various strands of
membership um we have we have members
who are family and individual
memberships so we furnish um tax
invoices to those members every year for
membership services the other strands of
membership are life members and
endowment members so they are
significant sums of money $1,000 for
endowment member $250 for life member
our auditors treat them as oneoff
donations so they don't appear in the
membership thing they are donations that
are directed to the um endowment fund so
people make those donations on the
understanding that they're invested
prudently and that the income from that
goes towards basic cost but mostly
mostly looking after the collection
mostly looking after insurance of the
collection so um and
obviously um it's a very good thing to
have when interest rates are over 5% um
when they have 0.8% as they were for a
couple of years prior and particularly
during Co um I have to admit it was it
was a good thing to have but it didn't
deliver much on the on the ground so the
the 40,000 that comes from Council I I
couldn't see what what's that purpose
used for then um we still have basic um
costs which is all Administration audit
subs and licenses as you can see in the
um okay repairs and maintenance that we
we cover a lot of that because we own
the interior of the building that's been
pretty spare we're going to be spending
quite a lot more money uh than than the
3,800 in the next in the next year or so
because all our displays are 20 years
old and they've got to be all upgraded
and um a lot of upgrading there and
that's the responsibility of the
organization uh we still pay for light a
portion of light power heating Security
phone um and general activity Insurance
um is not only the collection but it's
also um all our fixtures and fittings
it's our property at eore it's also we
um get insurance cover for anything that
comes in and out of the gallery which is
local people's exhibitions or if we get
National exhibitions we've got to have a
a degree of cover doorto door cover um
uh and also because you've got
kpis uh that that you've requested that
we meet um um as you see on that bottom
line we've sort of a portion roughly 15%
um of the cost of Meeting those and
that's to KP to support exibitions and
exibition programs but that's a very
small and nominal F sum within the
greatest scheme of
things Council Dixon thank you Mr chair
I just have um I was wondering Jim your
financial accounts end June 22 yes so do
you foresee that there be too many
changes in your
23 no I think um it'll be business as
usual there will be some
significant fund we've had a lot of
significant fundraising that will be
probably on par we may notice uh an
increase in income from investments from
interest um I just have to consult with
the treasurer about when when the ter
deposits were rolled over to the new
interest rate so there'll be but of
course this costs go up too so I think
um we we see it pretty much as status
quo and as I mentioned before $440,000
is is is um it's a small proportion of
our operating budget or um 27% but it's
really valuable and we're very happy
with it with the level that that uh for
the foreseeable
future any further
questions I have not ERS thank you very
much Jim for that presentation we just
carry on for the next one then thank
you um and apologies for um from Gus
Historical Society president Helen uh
president Helen Satan she's um unwell at
this point not able to um be present so
um again like the um East and Southland
Gallery um the G District Historical
Society um accountability forms fairly
straightforward and we also have a um
memorandum of understanding um with
Council that also um highlights some
requirements that is that plays an
active role in the precinct engaging 50
school and special interest groups perom
uh the museum has open 361 days and
meets a satisfaction rate you will
realize that the Museum's currently
closed it's been closed since um the
Redevelopment of the precinct in um uh
uh late uh
2019 G historical societies and
extraordinary
organization um it basically holds all
the records um of the very early Gore
and surrounding districts early sist
Association which was a very vigorous
group established in the early
1920s um Historical Society not only
collects artifacts and objects actually
that's fairly small part of what they do
um they collect information they an
extraordinary archive um I think there's
something in the vicinity of 35 the
photographic holding is over 35,000
images to track the history of Gore um
there's also a lot of material that's
come from very histories very um uh
material for the um scoping and
establishment of Publications in more
recent years it has been an archive for
the Matata inside and the gore
publishing company that was a massive um
input of of cultural material as is um
Flemings Mill trailer loads and Van
loads of material critical to the
interpreting the history of of of that
Enterprise is now with the museum as is
many many records that relate to a um
wider district from Community groups
from churches from schools um and we've
had a group then under particularly
under wi Hamilton the late wi Hamilton
who they were
vigorously sifting information and
Gathering what was critical to people's
understanding of their history
interestingly um we now find that one of
our biggest clients is G District
Council um because you'll realize that
when you lost your Civic administration
building in by fire in 1958 you think
pre 1958 material is now thankfully
because of G district is historical
society and its predecessors um we do
now have that so it's often that
planning building control um three
Waters parks and recreation use their
resources a lot um there's been a quiet
move on the part of um volunteers
committee and
staff while the museum has been closed
to the public to maintain Research
Services um albe it by phone online or
or by appointment but undertake a
digitization
program uh one that was begun by the um
Gore publishing company and which has
been carried on and with a joint venture
with
um um uh National Library of New Zealand
and that's essentially to scope our
history and record and digitize
everything that we've got Gore's got a
remarkable history of recording history
if you look at the Publications that
have come and certainly from the G
Publishing Company published and
published journals and histories about
everything in this part of the world so
um we clearly a small place that greatly
values its Heritage by virtue of the
enormous number of volumes of of
information that the museum has So the
plan is that um its status quo at this
point with the refit of the wi Hamilton
wing and um its final home at the M
White
Center um what was interesting I and we
discussed with the gallery that it was
essentially the gallery was fully
fundraised by other people that was the
same situation with the um hwui Heritage
Center Hui Heritage Center that was a
$1.4 million project that was um I think
council's contribution was a $50,000
interest free loan which it eventually
rid off everything else was fundraised a
big component of that was Gore District
historical society's previous Museum
which was the former fire station
building and they very kindly agreed to
sell those premises and vest all the
proceeds of that sale into the PO her
Center and of course that was the
seeding finance that enabled us to work
with lotteries work with Community Trust
South and MLT all those other people to
actually deliver that that project so we
owe them a lot there's kind of the
corner the Cornerstone of the gallery
they're the Cornerstone of the um
moonshine Museum the corner Stone of of
um certainly what the G group of
genealogists and all those other um
align groups deliver so they get a quite
a modest um
$11,000 the interestingly looking at
their
accounts they don't account for enormous
amount of activity um there was a lot of
work undertaken with the collection to
prepare it for the move to the m center
undertaken by um skilled people and
contractors but those fees and charges
were um covered by
individuals um who just said let's get
it done and we'll pay for it um there's
a huge again another huge community of
interest there um very very quiet but
very very solid support on the part of
the wider community so in in that regard
the um what's outlined in the in the
annual accounts is is the Tiff of Tiff
of the iceb and of public investment in
that place so again the $11,000 is um a
portioned across basic operations um and
again
um the committee is very happy with that
Grant they greatly appreciate it and
don't
foresee a need to increase it in the in
the foreseeable future interestingly
with a grants they're not CPI adjusted
um so we just sort of run with it until
such Point as you actually need to
address it um but that's a that's a
bigger discussion for Council as a whole
you know do you do you fce CPI
adjustments into these and make it less
painful for you when the time comes that
you actually need to up up the ante um
but as I as I mentioned the community of
interests surrounding all all their
museums all their Heritage um
organizations um is of enormous
assistance and um and it's greatly
appreciated as as Council support
thank you very much Jim for that uh very
informative um report is there any
questions from councilors Council
o the um 2500 and I just want to check
I'm interpreting it correctly for
display development as the figure of 35%
so does that 2500 represent about a
third of the money that's been spent on
display development on a specific
display development and that relates to
the clings display which is going to be
the first cab off the rank in the new
Mur wi Center so it basically looks at
um the physical
um development of interpretation panels
to augment the new displays that are
going there so there was there was a
project there which um uh
was that's 35% of what what those bills
were but of course there was other um
elements of those displays which have
been very kindly paid for privately by
yeah contributors so the projects and
activities what what of which the 3,100
is about 10% of it what what's that um
in order to to counter the fact that
they're closed um the society undertakes
quite a few activities so there's bus
trps for um senior citizens um and they
have room meetings um so they will get
guest speakers in to talk on Heritage
subjects so they have one of those a
month and they um have them in the new
library and new H room rumor at the at
the library um there's other activities
which relate to Gathering the members
together um because if you've got a
membership and you've got no museum open
then the membership's got the potential
to drift away so you've got to have
activities to make things happen so
that's and little
projects so when when when will the
museum open
again the what our focus is at the
moment and you will realize from the
council tour that we did of the wind
Hamilton Wing essentially the upstairs
is going to be dedicated to volb
collection items which is um
photographic collection textiles
archives anything vulnerable is going to
be on the first floor off the flood
plane everything downstairs is going to
be um resilient objects now they are
going to all be nested and packed and
nice new archival shelving so
essentially that is ready to go what we
have to do is we have to take everything
out of the ground floor one wing and put
it into the madur wi Center sift it
decide what works we're going to include
in our new displays move all the fings
material which is currently in storage
and assemble those
displays they will and then um our next
critical bit is to shift the research
center which is a joint venture between
the G District historical society and
the g group of
genealogists from the downstairs of the
wi Hamilton Wing into the new research
publicly accessible Research Center
adjacent to the visitor information
center um so there's going to be about
three activities happening in tandem
which is the fit out of the of the wind
Hamilton Wing the um fit out of the um
Research Center and the development of
the first wave of new displays and they
will be focused on if you look in the
window of the M wi Center it will be
focused on the carpeted area the nice
new area there there'll be petition
walls up in then displays which have
already been fabricated will go in there
the other big grunty displays are going
to essentially be in the area that's
been petitioned off um which which is
going to be um involve a lot of
fundraising um a lot of Grants and um
some significant research from guest
curators and guest
researchers but certainly as far and
that that area may take a little while
to um to commission but certainly the
others other areas will will be
commissioned reasonbly say so so the
timeline then well so are we talking
about the end of next year uh certainly
but well before then in terms of that
area the there could well be 12 months
work in the um Journey Through the Mato
Valley exhibition because there's a lot
of um interactive technology that's
going to be involved in that which costs
money um we've got input from guest
curators who are coming from around the
country to help us with that but
certainly the um Fleming's Mill display
will be first cab off the rank um and
all the other Heritage displays which
celebrate our um our rural history um
will happen within 12 months so one once
all that has happened and looking
forward um what's you you mentioned that
the the grant at the existing level is
sustainable um once the museum is open
again and and new location for Stuff
um what what does it look like in a
couple of years time in terms of what
your likely Demand on Council costs are
going to be through these grants I don't
see that it would be significantly
because we are in joint venture with G
Visitor Center we've also um uh we will
be running activities which once is
we're up and running which will generate
income um the the museum has had a
merchandising Wing which it hasn't been
able to operate since it's closed so
we'll be able to regenerate that and
we'll actually have a lot more space to
work with um given what uh the agreement
that Council has made with regard to the
kpis there are
some uh
costs which they will not be required to
meet with which is security cost of
security monitoring cost of the fire
system monitoring and the service
contracts relating to that um telephones
because that will come under the the
wing so there's are quite a few little
Elements which actually add up to um
quite a significant saving on the part
of the um on part of the host
organization thank you Mr chair um I
think it's amazing what you do
collecting our history and I hope we can
retain it here and it doesn't go
anywhere else um my question is around
donations uh are you finding with um
with their livelihood at the moment
which is pretty difficult for some
people and quite expensive that your
donations will slow down or do you think
that doesn't happen it it's a different
class of people that are going through
the the unsolicited ones have been quite
moving really we've just had two just in
very recent weeks um significant sums by
local families who want to invest in one
which is going to be specific to the
visit uh to the research center and
another one which is um going to be
spent on fit out of displays and
interpretation and digitalization
they're going to keep coming um and
there's been a history of that with with
not only the Historical Society but with
the gallery as well as's a community of
Interest no we see them if if anything
they'll increase once the um Historical
Society the work of fitting out the new
center was actually going
to um get out into the wider community
and people are going to start supporting
it so any other further questions
Council M
now just uh Jim Your Community Trust or
Community found trust or the trust sorry
get the words right the trust Community
Foundation uh that that Grant is that an
annual Grant to you uh that's a that's a
joint venture with um
MLT and that's that's for the purpose of
um senior citizens um activities here so
we um organization partners with you
yep no further
questions well once again thank you for
that comprehensive report and thank you
for um be up Council will make a a um
decision about what's going to happen in
the future and and we'll get back to you
as soon as possible yeah well as as as
everybody said our societies are very
very grateful for the support we get
from Council it's greatly appreciated
and greatly valued and
it because it's focused on those
basic operational costs that means our
committees and our donors can actually
focus on funding stuff that the people
enjoy the people see and interact with
um it's very hard
for
um workers and volunteers who will raise
money to pay P
bills thank
you
um we got anything from the chief if you
want to report any you more than happy
withing I think um as far as you're
concerned the the process from now on
will be just to ratify this at the
next
just through you um Steve it'll why does
it need to come through the well-being
committee could it not just go straight
to
council I
think
so what are we meant to do with it like
when it comes to us are we just
accepting the report and
basically
okay
so so we still start then with um is
there any comment then that any councils
want to make about the Mata here did
Center the Grant
from do you sorry before that do you
want to make any
comment
one thing that I did pick up today
actually and it's something that
again I think is important for you to
consider and for us to consider from a
operational perspective alongside you uh
is and Jim referenced it is the
community grants
policy um and i' you know to be
perfectly honest I'd overlooked it but
when Jim relayed back the actual
objectives of the policy um it's quite
clear there's a focus on a lot of this a
lot of what is being granted under that
Arts and Heritage area you know comes
back to to support the the policy states
to support the district's art galleries
and museums in the acknowledgement that
the gore district is an art center of
national importance and that its history
needs to be preserved so any decisions
need to also be come back to that policy
and the policy implications related to
it I think the policy is quite clear
there that there is a strong and while
the policy was I looked at it it was
adopted in
2012 um I think that that's something
that is is a Cornerstone for to assist
you in those decisions going forward as
well thank you Mr hav
thenon the um and and thank you to um
chief executive and deputy chief
executive for those because it just
reinforced um my thinking that our role
here is twofold today and of the four
presentations we've had we've had one
from a community group that is extremely
reliant on on our funding and and to go
to your question in terms of comments on
the Mata Heritage or historic group uh
they're quite open if we don't get it we
don't um we can't operate um so you'd
almost in my view that one's at the top
of the list that that um needs to be
preserved um the issue that we've got
with the other three that we've heard
about here today
is that we're providing funding through
other means to all of them and I find it
a little bit difficult just to deal with
them and uh with the Grant in isolation
to to what we're doing as part of the
the overall package and while I'm quite
comfortable from the point of view of
saying the amounts that we've given them
um have have been spent appropriately
I've got one little Rider with one of
them later um is is to what we're we're
exactly giving the money for um I'm I'm
satisfied that it has been spent um uh
appropriately and quite happy for it to
I guess go to the next stage I I see our
role really as a sifting role um before
it goes before the full Council to work
out the priorities of where we spend our
limited
funds and um I I um you I'm comfortable
from the point of view that um it is
worthy putting all four of these up to
the next stage um in terms of um the big
picture counc
Dixon Council HOV covered what I was
going to
say any further discussion from
cast I I think if you're going to change
uh grants or juice grounds I think we've
got to give PE people some sort sort of
notice along along the way so I think
the long-term plan is the place to to
look at this rather than just go today
and say we're taking 5,000 off this one
and 2,000 off that one I think you need
to give them a bit of notice so they can
plan a wee bit that's my
view yeah I'm just looking through our
scope of activity there they definitely
the requirements there it's um I'm just
sticking around the
um which one is it lost my point one of
them there it's just yeah it's going
forward to to look at how it works in
the future um and what impact we're
going to have on it I think that comes
down to what's happening with Aviation
trust at least they they are bringing in
some sort of document or some some
policy that's going to be forward to
thinking on how it's how it's working I
think we have incorporate that into into
the process
somehow so do you want to for that as a
recommendation to go to the community
well-being committee
or
externally I would thought through Mr
chairman that your recommendation for
cro and Heritage Aviation trust would be
that um continued funding at the current
level is dependent upon a satisfactory
strategic plan being produced
to uh signal the expand the um yeah the
Improvement and sustainability of the uh
complex as
a um primary visit
attraction and that you would expect
that that strategic plan be produced
within the next how long you want but
maybe 6 months so it's a clear Call to
Arms to get that plan together and and
then once you've seen that plan if
you're satisfied you can then uh carry
on your
investment so so just before just
before so would that be in line withu to
with
them no that sits outside it Mr CH Mr
chairman I think the mou is probably
going to need to be refreshed it was 10
years old um but this is a direct result
of they want continued funding well
you're saying well great you've you've
got some green shoots of Hope with your
strategic plan we want to see that uh
completed in a timely way
and then we want to be satisfied about
the content of that plan so that we can
invest with
confidence and and I think as a result
of that you would then review the Mi as
well Miu
sorry thank you there because clar um Su
would you like to BR readback that
recommendation
and
thank you you've all heard that
recommendation it was moved by Council
Str do we have a second for that
recommendation second Council M now so
all all those in favor for that
recommendation on behalf of the C
Aviation Heritage Trust go forward to
the community wellbe all those in
favor against
carried um within that recommendation do
we need to review the
mou uh no not at the stage I think I
think we could be part of a a general
discussion with the the community
well-being committee would that be
correct
um through Mr chairman I think look
primarily this committee is about uh
grant funding um but if there is an
underpinning instrument that needs
attention you could add it to your
recommendation so you could say and that
uh I would probably suggest that the
subcommittee note that the mou is
presently 10 years of age and
um uh strongly recommends that a review
be undertaking undertaken um on a
similar timeline as the strp plan that
we talk about six
months so what probably just better just
to add that on to the recommendation
yeah um Susan's would you like just add
that onto the recommendation and that
that forward the recommendation on this
committee to go to the wellbeing
committee to look at the
emo thank
you here are the Mover and the second
are happy with that change to the
recommendation okay thank you all those
in
favor carried so let's go back then to
the first one then uh mat here atender
for myself I don't believe it's a it's a
no Brer and and the aspect is that um
Mata was actually the first so s to call
cab off the rank for the project AR um
and what she was talking about the eive
is the uh online documentation of all
the assets of the museum and Mata was
the first one and if you ever get a
chance to go down and have a look it's
pretty unique and it's quite
amazing
sorry uh what areas are they open
approximately one to one to four three
days a week Friday Saturday Sunday oh
personally I'd like to
would
yeah so say that can we have a move in a
second for that move by Council de we
have a second second by Council Mell all
those in favor against carried
sorry we'll deal with um the South and
gallery and the gore Historical Society
do you want to deal with those
separately or do you just want to put
them left together
separately
okay so eastn Southern
Gallery any comment from any
counselors if not then can we have a
mover for that please in a second
Council second Council M all those in
favor I against
carried then just point of clarification
Mr chman so that's the moveing second
that the existing level of funding be
continued correct as requested from them
thank
you cor historical
assy I have a question and it's whether
and and their projects and activities I
know it's only a small amount that the
activities are holding
meetings and whether we should be
providing funding for holding meetings
I'm quite comfortable for the funding to
be used for the electricity and the
phone and everything else um because
that's an essential part of keeping the
doors open um but um whether it
extends I should have really drilled
into it a bit more in terms of of are
they paying people to come along is it
for room high or or what is it um so I'd
actually like to see a little bit of
clarification about that having thought
about it for the last five
minutes I know it's only a small amount
but it could well apply to some of the
other organizations that we're dealing
with as well you know what is our role
in terms of providing the funding to
help keep the doors
open yeah I I'm just not quite sure why
you think that I I I believe that if you
haven't got your core group of people
you haven't got any society and and I
think it's just
a I can understand your thinking but um
to me what they're doing is while
they've been in limbo while they're in
limbo that's what they're doing they're
having activities to try and keep that
Core group of society group together so
that they can
continue I think that's what Jim was
sort of indicating at the moment not
sure so are you recommending that apart
from that funding of the group meetings
you're more than willing to no I'm not
I'm not going as far as as putting it
into a recommendation I'm I'm just
posing it as an issue in terms of moving
forward um do we need to have more
clarity in terms of what the money is
used for as I said it's only a small
amount but it could apply to other
organizations that that we're dealing
with J I'm afraid I can't help in this
one because I took a phone call so I
missed probably uh two-thirds of the
presentation so um I'm not really kind
of sure where Council HOV was coming
from that because of my absence
sorry so Mr chair I'm just like it says
projects and activities does that
actually include meetings like we we
really don't know I thought it was the
planning going into projects yeah I I
sorry to interrupt I I actually asked
what are the activities and and the
answer I got was it's holding
meetings
I see your point too if you're trying to
keep that that and I can understand
where you're coming from for this for
this current I think for the last two
years well we've had hardly anybody
coming in and the fact is that they
haven't got any projects to make
or um carry on with until the mirow
project is actually finished and
completed they're basically in
limbo and I think that's where Jim's
basically coming from but if you want to
hold off and and perhaps ask some
clarification on those um you're more
than we can can do see that would be is
that
possible and then he can make a he can
make a report a further report to that
or clarification to
that
so we could pass this one as uh as it is
but look at
theou on it as well I think yeah Mr
chair one of the things I've often
wondered with theal Society is who is
behind it who are the who are the who
are the the people you know just behind
Jim and I know
there's two or three I've I've heard
about who are absolute St warts but it
would be interesting to know the
membership and looking at the the future
sustainability of the organization or
whether it eventually could morphen do
another entity in its entirety uh given
the the different um trusts at play in
the precinct but that's probably um
potentially related to to council hov's
concerns about well they're having
meetings um just finding a little bit
more about you've got the financials but
the actual people behind the society um
and it's future
intentions okay so yeah so is there
anyone willing to forward a Rec
Commendation if
not well I think um it probably go along
the same line as the first
recommendation um that we're probably
willing to
accept the Grant pass it on to the the
community well-being committee with
further information from Jim Gettys and
the review of the M us with Council and
the identity would that
be that what you want
if I may a note on page 59 of our agenda
it's got a list of the elected
members um and um so so there are a few
people involved but I guess to pick up
on the discussion I'd be quite
comfortable given that um it's going to
be probably another year before they're
able to open to continue at at the
current rate um but to note that um Mo
moving forward uh there is a need to
review um the funding that's
provided um not only through through the
grants but through other means as
well and I'll be happy to move it in
there yes is that a
recommendation did you get that Susan or
do you want him to repeat
that
no no no no no counc just um put his own
recommendation
through
yes and and other
funding and and picking up on on I think
um Council McKenzie's comment I think
was that you can't make changes without
actually giving a little bit of warning
and um looking ahead but with the
Redevelopment that we've got going on in
that area oh sorry was
it it's okay um with the Redevelopment
we've got going in that area I think
this is one of those cases where we need
to be um looking at the overall package
you again as to how Council provides
through grants or other means
Mr
chair um thank you Mr chair um what I'm
just wondering I thought that this m was
quite recent like
200 20 202 yes so um it wouldn't be up
for review well it can I guess
so yeah do I think do you want isn't
your main concern about its future
intentions so rather than put them to
the expense of a strategic plan but the
future intentions uh of the society
given the changes within the
precinct um and the modest level of
current activity as um portrayed by
today's
presentation and I would have thought
that that's the type of question you
want to to see the Clarity you'd like to
see uh
for further funding to be Advanced
beyond the next 12
months is that the essence of the
question so I think that would be the
the way you wrap that motion and that in
that
direction How does it go that Time
season
sorry
that's that's excellent no I think
that's fine are you more than happy with
that Council y are you going to move in
that direction okay yes move by Council
H second
yeah it yeah what what i envisage is
that this message will get to the
society say you need to come to us with
a group of your committee and with some
definitive ideas about what you've been
going to be doing the next few years and
and give the committee a degree of
confidence that um that further funding
uh grants can be made available and that
you're not just warming a seat and and
staying still you
know okay so we have our moveing us
second do we all those in favor right
against carried all right if there's no
further General business
um any councelor want to bring forward
in regards to anything on the grants if
not I declare the meeting closed and
thank you for your attendance and